[Applause]
welcome to the
archives of wwe where we have over 10
000 artifacts that have been collected
throughout time
this archive is over a hundred thousand
square feet
and it's pretty much filled to the brim
we do have a professional archivist who
makes sure that everything is
categorized organized
treated restored you know with all the
proper technology
that's necessary come this way
[Applause]
you have the bella twins and their ring
gear
two identical costumes for a pair of
identical twins this is actually the
ring gear that they wore
during wrestlemania 25 and you know
they've been a huge part of wwe just
inducted into our hall of fame they
really are just
remarkable human beings and it's awesome
to be able to catch
capture this piece of history
here you have the rocks championship
belt the brahma bull belt
now what's interesting about this is
it's actually never seen the light of
day it's never been on television
i mean this is really a premium
one-of-a-kind artifact
and it was created during you know the
rock and stone cold steve austin's
storyline
austin you want your belt you take it to
hell with you
and in stone cold had the smoking skull
belt
and then it was well should the rock
have his own championship belt and of
course yes
this was created lost in the mail
believe it or not
during those two weeks that it was lost
the decision was made to scrap
the whole thing how dare you and the
rock never got his own customized
championship belt but here it is
and here you have john cena from his
thugonomics days
when he was more of a bad guy or a heel
in the parlance of our business
and he did this whole character he sang
his own song produced his own song it's
word life
you know he'd do this whole thing he
sort of had this character and he wore
this big master lock chain
the old man's got a plan and he's
chilling in the building did i tell you
i'm like light beer i taste great and
i'm less feeling
but where it really started was actually
on a plane ride back from the uk
and i found out that cena could free
flow and he could just rap on the spot
and so i sort of put him to the test on
that and he was so
impressive and that kind of was the back
story behind how the character
really started these are pictures of
gorgeous george who was one of the
original
flamboyant characters better be careful
judgey
a long time ago actually muhammad ali
bob dylan a few very famous people
actually patterned themselves off of
gorgeous george
pretty remarkable actually when you
think about it this is
the rocks for sure and i remember
many times seeing the rock up in the
corner
wearing one of these very fancy
button-down shirts and getting stuck in
it and having a very hard time getting
out of the shirts
ring bell from madison square garden you
know signaling
signaling the beginning or the end of of
any match
and let's get the verdict here we have
the money in the bank briefcase
the wrestling album oh my goodness
[Music]
you had my father from a very long time
ago jesse ventura mean g no girl and
randy savage howard finkel i mean you
name it
andre the giants boots
[Applause]
he actually andre had uh broken his
ankle at one point and
he has a cast that was in my father's
office and when i was a little girl i
used to play
in it because even his ankle cast was
like the size of
my body when i was a little girl these
are
championship belt side plates for
customization
this is the dx invasion helmet we were
in the middle of the monday night wars
with
ted turner and wcw at the time
our funeral parlor these are actually
all of the caskets that have been used
for various shoots or events or
matches throughout the undertaker's
30-year career
oh my god the dead has risen
he's either been in them or he has put
people in them or he has shoveled dirt
into them
you know whatever whatever the need was
floor to ceiling of wwe memorabilia
unexpected
treasures and you know i guess from from
beginning to end
i don't know if i'm going to get in
trouble for this
i have a little head
it's amazing how actual pieces of
time you know they just bring you right
back
and and they create this this memory
that that
it's it's an emotional connection to
different parts of time in your life
and uh you'll see throughout the show
you'll see our superstars talk about
what these items meant and what happened
when they were wearing them or when they
were holding them
you know it's really it lets your
imagination take over
the most impressive item it's you know
it is totally subjective
because really all of these items mean
different things to different people
i mean this is the history of our
business
most everything is uh is priceless but
probably the the million dollar
championship belt might be the most
expensive
that would be the million dollar man ted
dibiase so there's about
over 10 000 artifacts here um you know
that that are
warehoused and archived and all that
great stuff but there's still about
95 of the memorabilia out there that is
still out there
um that we haven't had a chance to
collect that we haven't had a chance to
find
um and when you think about this show
like andre the giants passport
you know you have the undertaker's you
know initial gear
you know and even if you're not a wwe
fan i think you've probably heard of the
undertaker hopefully in the sense of wwe
um but there's you know all of these
different incredible
pieces that are just still out there and
it's our job to find them
there's a lot of big star items that
that we're still looking for i mean
we're really only just scratching the
surface
um the the most wanted treasures is
is really about these these big iconic
items
i mean even jake the snake's bag where
he used to keep his
snake you know for for those who used to
watch you know back in the 80s
but that bag we're actually looking for
um
andre the giants mask that he actually
wore
um his passport you know which is
particularly meaningful to me
because i grew up with andre and he was
kind of my best friend
and you know my my mom called him my
personal gulliver
but this passport knowing his life story
and
just thinking about all of the different
places you know he grew up on a farm in
france
and he just never stopped growing
because of a tumor that he had
called acromeglia that's how he became a
giant a literal giant
but when you think about all of the
different places he was and whether it
was japan or hawaii or just
all over the world how he had to
have multiple seats right like a
the real world is not meant to
accommodate a giant
um so all of the things that he went
through during during his travels and
and how crowds received him or didn't
receive him and
how he was treated it's just this
passport brought
so many things to life for me and it's
so
hard to imagine that one little thing
you know or the thought of something
could bring about
that many memories
i think wwe is really the foundation of
anything you want to do be it in
business
in media and sports you know hollywood
you name it
you not only have the opportunity to
perform in front of live audiences
and and what we do is really performance
art and a lot of improv
right because you engage and and you
react
off of the live audience the live
audience actually influences a lot of
what we do in the ring
but you're also trained from the
beginning you know you you're trained to
be a professional you're trained to show
up on time you're trained to
shake people's hands and look them in
the eye you're trained to know your
lines i mean all of these things that
you would imagine
you know a professional would do i think
it's really uh
the best training ground possible you
know for for
anything you want to do in life
you